life isn't about finding yourself
life is about creating yourself
make it a rule
never to give a child a book
you would not read yourself
do not do unto others
as you would that they should do unto
you
their tastes may not be the same
you see things
you say
why
but i dream of things that never were
and i say
why not
the reasonable man adapts himself to the
world
the unreasonable one persists in trying
to adapt the world to himself
therefore
all progress depends
on the unreasonable man
those who cannot change their minds
cannot change anything
there is no love more sincere
than the love of food
both optimists
and pessimists
contribute to society
the optimist invents the aeroplane
the pessimist
the parachute
the single biggest problem in
communication
is the illusion that it has taken place
the liar's punishment is not in the
least that he has not believed
but that he cannot believe anyone else
success
does not consist in never making
mistakes
but in never making the same one a
second time
patriotism is
a conviction that a particular country
is the best in the world
because you were born in it
he knows nothing
and he thinks he knows
everything that points clearly to a
political career
you use a glass mirror to see your face
you use works of art
to see your soul
dancing is a perpendicular expression
of a horizontal desire
[Music]
a pessimist
is a man who thinks everybody is as
nasty as himself
and hates them for it
my way of joking is to tell the truth
it's the funniest joke in the world
after all
the wrong road always leads somewhere
hatred is the coward's revenge for being
intimidated
you don't stop laughing when you grow
old
you grow old when you stop laughing
liberty means responsibility
that is why most men dread it
when a thing is funny
search it carefully for a hidden truth
better keep yourself clean and bright
you are the window through which you
must see the world
all great truths begin as
blasphemies
liquor is the chloroform which enables
the poor man to endure the painful
operation of living
[Music]
the most tragic thing in the world
is a man of genius
who is not a man of honor
life does not cease to be funny when
people die anymore then it ceases to be
serious when people laugh
criminals do not die by the hands of the
law
they die by the hands of other men
there are two tragedies in life
one is to lose your heart's desire
the other is to gain it
we learn from experience that men never
learn anything from experience
he who can
does
he who cannot
teaches
imagination is the beginning of creation
you imagine what you desire
you will what you imagine
and at last you create
what you will
a woman always chooses the men
who choose a different woman
never wrestle with pigs
you both get dirty
and the pig likes it
you'll never have a quiet world
till you knock the patriotism
out of the human race
animals are my friends
and i don't eat my friends
when a stupid man is doing something he
is ashamed of
he always declares
that it is his duty
[Music]
doing what needs to be done may not make
you happy
but it will make you great
all men are the same in front of the
woman
they admire
life is no brief candle to me
it is a sort of splendid torch which i
have got a hold of for the moment
and i want to make it burn as brightly
as possible
before handing it on to future
generations
[Music]
you